Kamala Harris drops out the other 2020
presidential candidates jockey for
position in House Democrats released
their massive 300 page impeachment
report I am Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a VPN yet I mean seriously what
are you waiting for visit expressvpn
comm slash pen well it's a sad day a sad
day because one of our favorite
candidates here at the ben shapiro show
Kamala Harris the illustrious senator
from my home state who was a terrible
Attorney General and she's a terrible
senator most well known in the Senate
for pushing conspiracy theories about
how Brett Kavanaugh was potentially a
gang rapists and pushing standards of
evidence that would not pass like a
straight jury trial in any normal County
in the United States Kamala Harris
who soared to the lead very briefly and
then immediately crashed and burned like
the Hindenburg well finally she called
it quits yesterday months in advance of
the first primary which is pretty
shocking considering that my theory was
that this was gonna be sort of a Wheel
of Fortune that basically everybody was
gonna get a shot at the top that if
Kamala Harris had stuck around long
enough the media would have done second
look at common law well instead she
dropped out yesterday and honestly I'm
really sad about all I can think about
are all the memories we shared together
you
Harris now for folks you can't actually
watch the show the reason you need to
subscribe so you can see all the
beautiful montages our producers cut of
Barbra Streisand singing memory laughing
like a crazed hyena my favorite tweet on
all of this by the way was comes from
the inestimable horrible columnist
Jennifer Rubin so Jennifer Rubin you'll
recall was once the conservative
columnist for The Washington Post and
then instead of just getting rid of her
when it was obvious that she was not
conservative they just were like oh yeah
she's not our conservative columnist
anymore she's just not conservative she
said she'll remain our column is she
just won't be conservative anymore which
I guess is one way to approach it but
for years they kept calling her
conservative even if she kept moving in
to the left and Celeste so she tweeted
out after all of this if empathy and joy
determined to presidential elections
Harris would lap the field if by empathy
you mean complete executive tyranny and
locking up Trent mothers absolutely
and if by joy you mean creepy
inappropriate laughter that puts you
seconds on the list to succeed joaquin
phoenix then sure empathy and joy
empathy and joy commoners by the way
it's not that we revel in the downfall
of political adversaries there are all
sorts of people on the left we're gonna
drop out of this race and you're not
gonna hear me cheer them bado i chaired
that occurred because bado is actually
awful and wanted to run roughshod over
our rights welcome Oh Harris is exactly
the same except she's more cynical and
more calculated and I think more
dangerous so her going she gets exactly
what she deserves every bit of mockery
is earned the fact that her campaign
soared to the top and then absolutely
flamed out Icarus flying too close to
the Sun and those wings just melting
quite beautiful I think it says
something good about the Democratic
Party honestly that Harris is out one of
the things that I think that it says
that is good is that black voters in the
Democratic Party never latched on to
Harris which is great because frankly
identity politics sucks and if they
latched on to Harris simply because of
the color of her skin or if they latched
on to Cory Booker simply because of the
color of his skin that became a racist
the fact that black voters have turned
toward Joe Biden instead of turning
toward Kamala Harris or Cory Booker is a
good thing for the country just like I
think that white voters should not judge
people on the basis of their color I
don't think they should only elect white
people I don't think the black voters
should only elect black people said that
says a good thing that the Democratic
Party
to have missed in their craze for
intersectionality and as we'll see the
media simply don't understand it the
media believe that the black community
in the United States black voters in the
United States should have resonated to
Cory Booker and Kamala Harris all the
white members of the media they cannot
understand why black voters didn't
automatically rush in droves to a
candidate as awful and off-putting as
Kamala Harris or as awful and
off-putting as Cory Booker who to be
fair it's a lot better than Kamala
Harris they can't understand it the
media's coverage of this is also
hilarious because the media seems to
have noticed that Elizabeth Warren is a
white person it only took them like
several years of claiming that she was
actually Native American to realize that
she is actually a white person we'll get
to all of that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that your car
right now in LA we are experiencing rain
I know this is not what I signed up for
well rain Sun wind dirt salt all of
these things wreck the look of your car
which is why I'm going to talk to you
now about the last coat it's a
proprietary versatile durable all-in-one
easy to use all surface do-it-yourself
coating that gives cars a slick
mirror-like finish in minutes it's also
great for glass vinyl leather stainless
steel counter tops electronic screens
most fabrics and a lot more it's a great
gift idea because Hagin protect pretty
much everything that's ever outdoors
using the last coat it creates a
protective shell on your car that
protects it from UV rays road salt
abrasive soaps extreme temperatures and
more the protection encoding lasts up to
six months they've got thousands of
five-star reviews online its 100% made
in the USA and you have a 365 day
money-back guarantee so you got nothing
to lose for a limited time my listeners
can get a 25% discount on a 16 ounce
bottle of the last coat the most durable
all surface DIY coating technology on
the market for reference an average
sized car takes like one or two ounces
for full coverage to take advantage of
the 25% discount text Ben 25 2 to 900 7
1 again text Ben 25 2 to 900 7 1 to get
25% off the last coat a great gift idea
for the car enthusiasts in your family
text Ben
25 2 to 900 7 1 to take advantage of
this limited time offer
okay so Kamala Harris put out the
announcement she also her husband put
out well honestly I was kind of a rather
sweet tweet of him hugging her and
saying I've still got you which is which
is nice but her campaign announcement
that she was suspending is
fairly ridiculous she says 11 months ago
at the launch of our campaign in
Auckland I told you all I am not perfect
but I will always speak with decency and
moral clarity and treat all people with
dignity and respect unless they are
accused to hunt mothers I'll throw them
in jail and threaten them or potential
Supreme Court justices who disagree with
me on Roe vs. Wade
then I will unfairly persecute them and
pretend that I have evidence that their
gang rapists shouldn't say that last
part that just is the part that's
that's true she says I will lead with
integrity I will speak the truth and
that's what I have tried to do every day
of this campaign so here's the truth
today I've taken stock and looked at
this from every angle and over the last
few days have come to one of the hardest
decisions of my life my campaign for
president simply doesn't have the
financial resources we need to continue
I'm not a billionaire
I can't fund my own campaign and as the
campaign has gone on it's become harder
and harder to raise the money we need to
compete now I will say it is
hysterically funny to watch as every
major Democrat now complains that
there's too much money in politics on
the Democratic side of the aisle we
haven't even reached the general
election yet and I'll show you all the
Democrats today are claiming that the
reason that Kamala Harris is out the
reason cory booker is experiencing
trouble is because they can't raise
money and if only they were billionaires
like what Joe Biden Joe Biden is I think
the poorest person on the Democratic
side of the aisle maybe if he booted
judge one of the two moody judge hasn't
been having trouble raising any money
because he's entrapped candidate Biden
has been having trouble raising money
but he's got name recognition so the
complaints that I'm not a billionaire so
I couldn't get ahead in this race there
was a point where commonly Harris was
your poll leader in fact there was a
point where she was bragging about how
she was your poll leader right after
Tulsi Gabbard slapped her during one of
the debates Kamala Harris said that she
was a top candidate in fact she was a
top-tier candidate this is one of the
charming things that makes Kamala Harris
one of the earliest candidates to drop
out of this race this is gonna sound
immodest but I'm obviously a top-tier
candidate and so I did expect that I
would be on the stage and take hits
tonight because there are a lot of
people that are trying to make the stage
for the next debate for a lot of them
it's do-or-die well yeah and especially
when people are at 0 1 percent or
whatever she might be at and so I did
expect that I might take it
by the way guess who's still in the race
tulsi gabbard now that by the way the
conventional wisdom that you're seeing
online which is that tulsi gabbard
slapping at Camilla Harris basically
killed Harris's candidacy that is not
true common-law Harris started dipping
in the polls as soon as she achieved the
lead because she's awful because she was
lying about her medicare-for-all plan
she flipped flopped on that eight
different ways from Sunday
because she lied about her own criminal
justice record because again she's
personally extremely off-putting I mean
more so than even people like Elizabeth
Warren more so than Cory Booker Tulsi
Gabbard I mean the subtlest cuts cut
deepest here's Tulsi Gabbard tweeting
out sending my best wishes to Kamala
Harris her family and supporters who
have campaigned so hard while we
disagree on some issues we agree on
others and I respect her sincere desire
to serve the American people I look
forward to working together on the
challenges we face as a nation
well that that kind of hurts considering
how to Elsie Gabbard stabs her directly
in the chest the earlier debates
remember this glorious moment when Tulsi
Gabbard just finished Kamala Harris on
the stage senator Harris says she's
proud of her record as a prosecutor and
that she'll be a prosecutor president
but I'm deeply concerned about this
record there are too many examples to
cite but she put over 1,500 people in
jail for marijuana violations and then
laughed about it when she was asked if
she ever smoked marijuana she blocked
evidence
would have freed an innocent man from
death row until the courts forced her to
do so she kept people in prison beyond
their sentences to use them as cheap
labor for the state of California and
she fought to keep them in place how we
well now it's tulsi gabbard Ventura fond
Aloha Aloha catch you later
don't see Gabby just sitting over there
strumming the ukulele having herself a
grand old time again it wasn't tulsi
gabbard they put Harris out of the race
it was Harris who put Harris out of the
race her original attack on Joe Biden
which sent her soaring in the polls and
the media just gushing over her was a
dishonest attack here is that this was
her big moment the her only big moment
in the race is when she was hitting Joe
Biden on forced busing suggesting that
Joe Biden was a racist for not
supporting forced busing in the 1970s by
the way she doesn't support forced
busing virtually no one really supported
forced busing in the nineteen seventies
because it was a bad policy forcing
children out of their local schools
forcing them on two buses to drive an
hour to schools where they knew no one
was a bad policy that ended with white
flight to suburban areas and different
local school districts I mean that's
what forced busing resulted in in fact
Hummel Harris knew that which is why she
doesn't back busing today it was obvious
I mean I talked about this at length of
the time I I think I did a full podcast
on common law Harris's dishonesty on
busing here is Kamala Harris attacking
Joe Biden this was her only great
moments in the race and it fell apart
immediately like immediately because it
was obvious that she was lying it was
hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two United States senators who built
their reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country and
it was not only that but you also worked
with them to oppose busing and you know
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me okay well it turned
out that her her whole story I'm busing
was at the very least deeply flawed and
also her attack on Biden for suggesting
that he had to work with senators he
didn't even like which was his actual
quote that backfired on her dramatically
but here's the good news we will always
have the bizarre off-putting Howard Dean
like video of Kamala Harris walking out
of a building and laughing at a bus
we'll always have that to share together
here's that video one last time as we
bid a fond farewell to Kamala Harris
[Music]
that was take seven as take seven the
first six takes we're not nearly as
enthusiastic but she had to really get
herself up for it look at her bus that
bus will now be repurposed back to the
California Department of Corrections
where it will jail low-level marijuana
violators at the behest of Kamala Harris
by the way I'm expecting the Department
of Corrections to show up at my door for
criticizing Kamala Harris because she's
still the senator from this awful state
the real downside to Kamala Harris
dropping out of the race is now she can
focus on making my home state even more
garbagey than it already is we will get
to more on the Democratic side of the
aisle more on the Democratic race
momentarily but first let's talk about
how you need better frames on pictures
you have at home okay the fact is that
an inexpensive frame can really make a
great portrait a great photo look crappy
and if you are looking for a great gift
idea where you want to give a friend
family member something that they will
cherish for a long time what you get
them is a really nice framed photo for a
Christmas we're doing this actually for
my grandmother right now the best way to
get a beautiful frame that's not gonna
cost you a fortune is to go over to
frame bridge if you've heard if you've
been listening to the show you've heard
me talk about frame bridge before they
make it easy and affordable to frame
your favorite things from art prints and
posters to all your best photos and with
the holidays fast approaching frame
bridge makes a perfect way to give a
great easy thoughtful gift in just
minutes you can turn a photo from your
phone into one of the best gifts ever so
here's how it works you go to frame
bridge comm you'll upload your photo you
prove you preview your item online in a
variety of frame styles or you select
one of their best-selling designs and
then the expert team at the frame bridge
Factory will custom frame your item and
deliver the finished piece straight to
you or anyone on your list
a handmade personalized gift from frame
bridge starts at 39 bucks she's in a lot
of money all the shipping is free plus
my listeners get 15% off their first
order at frame bridge comm when they use
my code Shapiro now I have this great
photo of me with my wife and kids we
sent it over to frame bridge we had it
framed this way it looks just fantastic
become a gift-giving legend by using
frame bridge you have high quality
one-of-a-kind gifts you can order in
minutes go to frame bridge comm use
promo code Shapiro
you'll save an additional 15% off that
first order go to frame bridge comm
promo code Shapiro frame bridge comm
promo code Shapiro so as I say it is
wonderful to watch all of the candidates
that Kamala Harris attacked now bid a
fond farewell here was Joe Biden bidding
her a fond farewell
it's a real competitor
no mixed emotion because she is really a
solid solid person I'm sure she's not
dropping out and wanting to make the
changes she cares about Joe Biden is
that he's so rank lay dishonest in so
many ways but every so often he says
things and his face betrays him as he
gets older the the sort of grin that he
pasted on that mug right it's becoming
more and more obvious when he's actually
happy inside and then entire clip he can
barely hold back from Torte link he can
barely hold back from chortling it's
great he's like I have mixed feelings
he's like I have mixed feelings about
this guy's agita like really mixed
feelings like like I can't even express
how mixed these feelings are hey if you
if you actually watched the clip he is
smiling well he says he has managed so
much she's so awful she's so awful well
the media's angle on this is of course
that everybody's a racist it's not that
she's a garbage candidate because Cory
Booker is still nice by the way and it's
not that we had I don't know a two-term
black president who was elected
overwhelmingly both times no it's that
everybody is racist again see how this
works you see how this works every time
a black person is elected that is
symptomatic of the fact that America has
moved has has somehow gotten past the
tone racism but only momentarily only
momentarily only for like eight years
and then Obama's no longer in office and
everybody goes right back to you know
what everybody's racist again weird
weird it's it's this idiotic bizarre
notion that that outcome determines
intent okay meaning that it's not that
intent two terms determines outcome is
that if the outcome is not what you want
then you can infer the intent from what
happened so if Barack Obama was elected
that means that the American people got
past racism for like half a second but
if they don't resonate to Comeau harris
or a cory booker mainly because both of
them are wildly rehearsed and Kamala
Harris was mechanical I mean she's just
a bad actress Cory Booker is over the
top he's like Al Pacino in Scent of a
Woman everything that Cory Booker does
is why
odd and crazy and so he is not caught on
with anyone he's also manipulative but
everybody sort of gets that but the
media's play is that if cory booker
criminal harris are not on the final
tomates age that is because democratic
voters are racist so like the I feel
like Emperor Palpatine in Return of the
Jedi good god yes do this media do this
please tell all the Democrats how they
are vastly racist because they don't
love Kamala Harris or Cory Booker and
basically the entire media we're doing
this right there was a whole MSNBC panel
explaining that Kamala Harris had it
rough because she's a black woman let's
be straight about this if Kamla Harris
were a white woman she never would have
been running for president in the first
place she's a what a first term senator
from California who is not popular in
her own home state no one likes her here
everybody kind of dislike okay come on
like really nobody's in she was going to
lose her home state the reason she
dropped out this early is because she
was going to completely bomb in her own
home state that's the reality hey the
only reason that she was considered a
national candidate is because the media
were calling her the female Obama they
were saying oh she's a black woman and
therefore she checks all the
intersectional boxes it's why everybody
saw her as a deep threat even though she
has no record she's produced no serious
legislation her main moment on the stage
of of the Senate was ripping into Brett
Kavanaugh on false auspices Komal Harris
by the way out of the presidential race
Brett Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court's
that's a win for president Trump right
there here's the MSNBC panel however
declaring that really comella a victim
she's a victim know if Harris's victim
of anything it's of the fact that she's
horrible that she's absolutely terrible
but here's MSNBC declaring that she had
it rough because she's a black woman
despite all the evidence that she
actually had it a lot easier from the
media specifically because she's a black
woman think that women are still held to
different standards as candidates they
have to have well-run campaigns
never mind that Donald Trump didn't have
a campaign he Lily flora would hope
ironing his pants they they have to be
perfect on the stub which she I never
saw her stumble Joe Biden is beloved I'm
a fan he's never perfect on this time I
mean I do think there is a gender piece
here that we still suck at talking about
she had the double-edged sword of not
just being a woman but being an
african-american woman and the judgment
and the standards that
had to deal with as that with that
baggage yes let the hate flow through
you every moment you become more my
servant yes yes great do this do this
seriously it's the double-edged sword
don't you see see the Democrats are
racist now the Democratic voters there
are the ones we're not pulling for her
Andrew yang was getting better numbers
than she was and it's because the
Democrat voters are racist so I'm glad
to see that MSNBC elites are now turning
to their own voting base and saying you
guys are racist because you didn't love
Kamala Harris it's wonderful and this
was the message across media yesterday
this was the message across media it
also carried a sort of covert message
that was hilarious so CNN's Brianna
Keilar she said now the stage I mean
look at this stage this stage is old and
white white so many white woo Keeler it
was a really interesting point there at
the end Jeff made this becomes an older
and wider field for the top tier
candidate it certainly does and I think
it's a lesson in how when you run for
the presidency you need to have a
message and you need to stick to it I
think she made a decision and her staff
made a decision that she just didn't
want to be embarrassed in her home state
and and you're right the field is
looking a lot wider and a lot older Wow
whiter older so bad quite old so Cory
Booker who is the last black candidate
left in the race Booker is like yeah man
now's my moment
sure I've only raised $7 so far and sure
nobody likes me and sure everybody is
sort of weirded out when in the middle
of a debate I reach I reach into my mr.
Potatohead back and pull out my angry
eyes but now's the moment because if I
can just get the Democratic base to
rally around the fact that they are
racist and they need to vote for a black
person then that will change everything
so here is Cory Booker on with Chris
Hayes last night so our debate stage
might have no diversity no diversity am
i enjoying this you bet your ass I am
because I don't think that skin color
diversity matters
I think ideological diversity matters I
think the quality of a candidate matters
but I'm amused to watch the Democrats
now hold their own voting base to their
own idiotic horrific
first standard here is cory booker
covertly calling the democratic party
racist if they don't nominate him it's
pretty great before she was a senator
presidential can excuse my friend she
was my sister and so today I'm a little
angry I have to say that we started with
one of the most diverse fields in our
history giving people pride and it's a
damn shame now that the only
african-american woman in this race who
has been speaking to issues that need to
be brought up is now no longer in it and
we're spiraling towards a debate stage
that potentially we're still fighting to
get on it but could have six people with
no diversity whatsoever you thought your
pitiful powers were a match for the dark
side of the force it's great like really
I'm enjoying this I'm enjoying because
you held Americans to this idiotic
standard it didn't matter that Americans
were perfectly willing to vote for a
black candidate for president two times
two times and by the way the first time
he was utterly unqualified for the
presidency he'd been in the Senate for
five seconds he'd never done a damn
thing except make a couple of speeches
about unifying America he proceeded to
completely divide America but he was
voted for twice but now I'm I love it
the Cory Booker is calling the
Democratic Party base racist that's what
he's doing by the way he put out an
email did Cory Booker in his desperation
he put out an email I'm on all the
Democratic candidate email us and
they're pretty fun this is Ben yeah Cory
said Ben I'll get right to the point six
candidates currently in the race are
qualified for the DNC's December debate
but as it stands now after starting with
the most diverse presidential fields in
our nation's history
you might not see our party's diversity
reflected on that stage not a single one
of the candidates who qualified for the
December debate is a person of color and
Ben that's a shame what he's really
saying is you know who's a person of
color
Cory McGee look over here this guy he's
got two thumbs and he's standing right
here Cory Booker that guy says these
thresholds have had the effect of
denying candidates of color access to
the debate stage while paving the way
for billionaires who are inflating their
support through massive ad buys ah so
now we're gonna rip on the people like
Tom Steyer who've been spending hundreds
of millions of their own dollars in a
quixotic campaign for the presidency now
listen that's his business if Tom Styer
wants to do that stupid thing Tom Steyer
can do that stupid thing but I am
enjoying the fact that Andrew yang is
not polling Cory Booker he ain't out
spending Cory Booker
so far as I'm aware he's raised some
money but that's cause he andrew yang is
not a charmless human being I love that
yeah I love that he is now ripping the
thresholds he's ripping the basic
standards for getting on the stage
because he can't surpass them
he says the race is still far from
decided no one knows who we will choose
our party's nominee but it would be
unacceptable if our final choices did
not reflect the rich diversity of our
party spoiler alert
your final choices will not reflect the
rich diversity of your party
it is a unilaterally homogeneously
leftist party and the fact that you've
ended with a bunch of white candidates
by the way I'm also enjoying the fact
that apparently we are now getting a
clarification of the hierarchical
intersectional standard that's exciting
apparently people who judges
homosexuality has no impact on his
standard here right he's just a white
guy but apparently Bernie Sanders is
Jewish atheism right now that has no
standard on the stage Elizabeth Warren
is a woman doesn't add diversity to the
stage he Amy Klobuchar as a woman
doesn't have diversity to the stage
really when the Democrats mean Aversa T
they mean diversity of skin color alone
which it's good to get that
clarification we'll get to more of the
Democratic Party turning in on itself
which is just wonderful let them fight
get to that in one second first let's
talk about something almost as delicious
as this democratic turning in on itself
that of course is Omaha Steaks Omaha
Steaks supremely delicious supremely
great according to everyone who has
tried them in fact Omaha Steaks has a
great deal for you for all your buddies
for Christmas okay it's just it's just
fantastic go check them out Omaha Steaks
has an amazing limited time offer for my
listeners you get a jump on your holiday
shopping head on over to Omaha Steaks
com entered the code Shapiro in the
search bar to order the favorite gift
package it's the gift anyone who loves
steak will love for just $69.99 order
now you'll get four six ounce
bacon-wrapped filet mignons for premium
pork chops for Omaha Steaks burgers for
perfectly browned potatoes au gratin for
made from scratch caramel apple tartlets
and Omaha Steaks signature seasoning
packet and for my listeners you get a
free six piece cutlery set and cutting
board that is one hell of a deal for
$69.99 get all that delicious food and
the cutlery set that whoever receives
the gift will enjoy for years to come
$69.99 again order now you get the
favorite gift package Plus that free six
piece cutlery set and cutting board for
just $69.99 head on over to Omaha Steaks
com types Shapiro and search by only
waiting at the deal
Omaha Steaks comm tape Shapiro in the
search bar don't wait the offer ends
soon ordered that favorite gift package
today I mean my goodness if I didn't
keep kosher you know how much I would
love to receive that gift package Oh
that'd be a great gift Omaha Steaks calm
Ted Shapiro in the search bar okay so
Cory Booker turning on the media turning
on his own party just put me on the
debate stage and I'll demonstrate that I
can and I have
United moderate and progressive
Democrats I'll demonstrate that I can
and I have excited and engaged black
voters the most loyal constituency of
our party well not only have you not
excited and engaged black voters you
have zero percent black support he says
he'll demonstrate he's the only person
in this race who can rebuild the
coalition that elected President Obama
we need in order to defeat Donald Trump
basically Cory Booker is saying that
only if we have a black nominee well
black voters show up which seems tacitly
racist does it not that the only way
that you're gonna get black voters to
show up in droves if you have a black
canted at the top of the ticket
that's that's a little racist okay so
that one is pretty funny that's it
that's one letter that's pretty funny
the other letter that is pretty funny
comes from Elizabeth Warren so as I say
I'm finding it high larious hilarious
that the entire media are now saying the
stage is old and white did they just
notice Elizabeth Warren's a white person
I was reliably informed by members of
the media that she because of her high
cheekbones and her Native American
heritage she was a representative
diversity on that stage she called
herself a Native American in like the
Harvard Law School yearbook for years
Elizabeth Warren was a member of the
indigenous tribes of America now
yesterday the media were pointing out
that the stage is old and white and Liz
Cheney too now don't forget about
Pocahontas and everyone went nuts how
could Liz Cheney say Pocahontas that's
so racist can we dispense with this
idiocy please and when when Trump calls
Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas Orin Liz
Cheney calls Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas
they're not making fun of Pocahontas
they're making fun of Elizabeth Warren
who lied about her own heritage and it
is ridiculous to me that the media focus
in on people pointing out that she has
stolen intersectional valor that the
mockery of her is somehow considered
that the mockery of her somehow
considered the racism as opposed to the
fact that she was masquerading as a
Native American for decades of her own
political and personal and professional
wife no Liz Cheney was not making fun of
Native Americans she was making fun of
Elizabeth Warren for pretending to be a
Native American for years we all do it
on the right why because it's insane and
ridiculous and the fact that the left
has decided to go along with it until
now apparently is hilarious though why
didn't comely Harris ever attack her on
this
I was always bewildered by this made no
sense to me Pamela Harris had an open
lane right there all she had to do was
slap Elizabeth Warren for pretending to
be Native American for years it is the
most obvious line of attack ever ever
and if she had attacked Elizabeth Warren
maybe she goes up in the polls again but
you know the going theory is that is
that Kamala Harris is campaigning for VP
well if Joe Biden's the nominee that
ain't happening Joe Biden cannot stand
her so it was with more and put out her
own letter on this it's it's so
wonderful to watch the Democrats apply
their own intersectional branding to the
commo Harris exit so well she was in
nobody liked her now that she's out
everybody is very angry at the
Democratic base that she's out so Cory
Booker is angry he's always angry see
apparently rosario Dawson packs his
angry eyes he takes out those angry eyes
puts those right into his face I'm so
angry at the Democratic base very angry
you get Elizabeth Warren right Elizabeth
Warren she's doing me and I'm very upset
- I'm so why's Elizabeth Warren upset
I'm upset because a woman a woman is out
well yeah so what you're a woman you're
there all right mean last I checked you
identify as a woman I mean I've even
checked on your bio and you say that
your preferred pronouns are she and hers
so I mean it seems like you're a woman
and Amy Klobuchar our last I checked is
a woman whether she's throwing binders
or not whether she's wood chipping or
staffer they're women on the stage but
Elizabeth Warren puts out a letter today
okay here's the letter from Elizabeth
Warren see already got Cory Booker going
I'm the only black person left on the
stage and if we love if we love racial
diversity you must nominate me and if
you don't I'm gonna whip out these
papers the judge doomed papers from
Roger Rabbit okay and then you got and
then Elizabeth Warren and here's her
letter I love this stuff so much
I do sometimes politics is fun the today
is one of
so here is the letter from fading
Elizabeth Warren who is gonna have to go
back to if you're Elizabeth Warren and
you fail in this race basically you have
to move to a Native American reservation
and then you have to sell sweaters right
I mean that's pretty much what you do
you just did a bunch of the same sweater
different colors like a rainbow variety
of sweaters maybe some Planned
Parenthood's scarves exciting stuff
so Elizabeth Warren she put out a letter
it says this Kamel Harrison kirsten
gillibrand two women senators women
senators who together won more than 11.5
million votes in their last elections
have been forced out of this race forced
don't you see
forced well billionaires Tom Styer and
Michael Bloomberg have been allowed to
buy their way and okay can I just
explain something no one forced Kamla
Harris out of this race she dropped out
there was nothing legally that forced
her to drop out she could have stuck
around and failed kirsten gillibrand -
and I love that Elizabeth Warren's like
these two women together one more than
11.5 million votes in their last
elections okay
Michael Bloomberg was the mayor of New
York okay how many votes were won in New
York yeah I would imagine millions of
votes for Mayor Bloomberg in New York
and in his mayoral tee he was winning
overwhelming percentages as mayor of New
York I don't see her aggregating his
voting statistics as mayor of New York
right in 2009 he won a extremely heavy
victory but apparently he's very bad
he's very bad and apparently kirsten
gillibrand is very good that's really
exciting stuff he was by the way in 2005
when he was re-elected mayor he was
reelected by a margin of 20% was a
pretty good stat for Mayor Bloomberg in
any case she says that it's the
billionaire's forcing people out so it's
that the Democrats are not just racist
they are also sexist
don't you see Elizabeth Warren who for a
brief period in time was leading the
race she was riding the plains of
Oklahoma on her trusty Mustang leading
this race well following the buffalo
herd she Elizabeth Warren is now
claiming that if she's not the nominee
it's because people are sexist it's
wonderful that that como Harris can play
this kaleidoscopic role for so many
Democrats for Cory Booker if Camille
Harris drops out it's
cuz the the Democratic populace is
racist unless they liked him for
Elizabeth Warren it's because the
Democratic populace is sexist if they
don't elect her and also classist
because they're favoring Tom Steyer and
Michael Bloomberg she says our party and
our democracy deserve better by the way
the only reason that Elizabeth Warren is
putting out this letter of course and
mentioned in Kirsten Gillibrand is
because of the woman card it'd be one
thing if she just said that Kamala
Harris was forced out by bigger money
but dropping Kirsten Gillibrand named
Kirsten Gillibrand was one of the first
people to drop out because Kirsten
Gillibrand had zero voters including
immediate family and everyone in her
immediate family was turning to her and
going Kirsten what are you doing what
are you doing so playing the woman card
for Elizabeth Warren so let them all do
this really I'm enjoying it we'll get to
the other Democratic candidates in just
one moment first let's talk about how
important it is for you to figure out an
investment strategy early on in your
life it's actually quite important the
more you invest now the more you will
earn later a compound interest is a
wonderful wonderful thing and if you
start investing now you have a smart
investment strategy the small amounts of
money you put in and we work a lot more
money later and the fact is
unfortunately people my generation
Millennials are under invested it's easy
to see why well 2008 was painful a lot
of companies make investing seem
complicated but so fight invest makes it
super easy for anyone to start investing
with as little as $1 you can even buy a
piece of companies like Amazon or Google
or Disney with sofa stock bits at
whatever amount you want which is pretty
awesome right you can't afford to buy
like an entire Apple share cuz those are
actually really expensive but you can
afford to buy like a slice of that and
then you own a small piece of Apple
right which is great so if I invest
makes investing simple to get started
here's how it works you go to sofa comm
slash Ben when you create an account you
choose to either do it yourself or let
so Phi's automatic automatic investing
build your portfolio for you use stock
bids to buy fractional shares of your
favorite stocks you can start with as
little as $1 see for yourself how easy
it is to start investing with Sophie at
Sophie comm slash bet and fund your sofa
invested count received twenty five
bucks in mystery stock which is free
stock and those are name-brand stocks go
to sofa comm slash Ben claim your free
stock today it's sof i.com
slash Ben so file ending Corp CFL number
six zero five four six one two already
so I'll get to the rest of Democratic
field and then we'll get to impeachment
cane we'll get to all of that in just a
second first if you're not already a
subscriber
you're really missing out head on over
to tail e wire comm / subscribe did you
miss our special deal over the weekend
well that's sad for you but the fact is
you can still buy in and like our normal
price and the normal price is still
pretty fantastic for as little as ten
bucks a month you get all of our
articles ad free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
water app which is a fantastic feature
if you haven't checked it out yet if you
choose the new All Access plan in all of
those magical things plus the legendary
leftist cheers tumbler and our brand-new
ask me anything style discussion feature
that allows you to engage our hosts
writers and special guests on a weekly
basis so stop depriving yourself come
join in the fun had a number two daily
wire.com slash subscribe we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
by the way speaking of Elizabeth Warren
who again has been fading badly badly in
the polls
she continues to fade because she
continues to make wild promises that are
utterly uncapable yesterday she was
asked by a small child if she will end
global warming here was her answer my
question is when you become president
are you going to stop global warming
brave child brave children they're our
future
yes I like that she's wearing the blue
sweater today sounds exciting si as I
know chilly was one outfit 10 different
sweaters pretty exciting huh yes she's
going to do so how by attacking the Sun
alternatively by launching our beach our
b-2 bombers we have to launch some
bombers we have to launch them in all
the coal mines in India and in China I
would just like to note that there's an
article from The Huffington Post today
about global carbon emissions hitting a
record high in 2019 you know which was
one country that actually lowered its
emissions buried deep down in this
article from The Huffington Post well
that would be the United States the
United States withdrew from the Paris
agreement also euro submissions are
predicted to fall by 1.7 percent over
2018 levels coal production will likely
decline by about 10 percent so for all
the talk about how the United States is
the real problem here we are actually in
a period of declining emissions while
emissions are rising pretty much
everywhere else
China and India being the leaders in
this sphere I'm looking forward to
Elizabeth Warren launching a full-scale
war I'm always amused by this idea that
though if we do not stop global warming
today we're all gonna die if that were
really true we would have to do
something to force China and India to
stop the emissions would we not right
what I mean to be fair isn't that what
they are the leading emitters by a long
shot and their emissions are going up
and are gonna continue to go up until at
least 2030 but don't worry Elizabeth
Warren will solve global warming just
like Barack Obama 2008 Iowa caucus
victory night this will be moment when
the rise of the season was slow yeah
that didn't happen Elizabeth Warren also
excitingly said she's gonna wear her
plank her pink Planned Parenthood scarf
when she was sworn in as president of
Candyland because she's not going to be
President of the United States here's
Elizabeth Warren I spoke and I wore my
pink Planned Parenthood scarf
now that's - so here's my plan for
number three I'm gonna be wearing that
scarf when I'm sworn in as president of
the United States see this scarf says
dead babies whoo yeah I can't imagine
why these Democrats are I mean Hillary
Clinton yesterday suggested she might
come back in I cannot imagine why by the
way Pete Buddha judge
supposed to be the moderate in this race
when Democrats aren't calling their own
voters racist they're calling everybody
erases so here's people to judge
yesterday campaigning in South Carolina
and suggesting that every single person
who voted for President Trump in 2016 or
is considering voting for Trump in 2020
is ignoring racism which is idiotic you
don't have to actually love everything
President Trump says to vote for him you
can disagree with many of the things
that he says you can disagree with his
mannerisms you can think that he is
unstable you can do lots of things and
still vote for him when faced with the
alternative of a very very bitter
Democratic Party intent on rewriting the
American bargain but here's people to
judge I mean this is a hell of a
strategy for winning back those moderate
swing voters call them racist Pete Oh at
best looking the other way at worst
they're just open racist all 63 million
people who voted for President Trump by
the way I just like to point out that
obviously people to judge is a homophobe
because you know way back when he
actually was smiling and standing in
front of a Salvation Army Red Kettle
during a charity drive so now who's not
woke Pete Buddha jej I mean first you
say things like not all educational
disparities are the result of systemic
discrimination which makes you a lying
imap4 according to Michael Harriet at
the root and then you stood in front of
a Salvation Army kettle
are you a self-hating gay person P Budaj
I'm not getting there seriously LGBTQ
activists or angry people to judge over
that that's the party he chose to belong
to ma'am you bought the ticket you take
the ride okay meanwhile impeachment Ward
renard fear and is moving for you may
have noticed that I'm not talking about
it too much on the show right now why
cuz boring we all know where this is
going okay the Democrats are going to
impeach Trump in the house and then this
is going nowhere in the Senate and
they're gonna do so on pretty scant the
evidence of actual impeachable crimes
how do we know that the evidence is
scanty well they released a 300-page
report yesterday that does not actually
back up its key assertions is released
by Adam B Schiff he wrote it in between
like during the during the commercial
breaks on CNN when he wasn't camped out
in the pup tent outside the greenroom
he wrote this three hundred page report
and he and he talked about how this is
that the president has committed crimes
crimes he says the decision to move
forward with an impeachment inquiry is
now
we took lightly under the best of
circumstances impeachment is a wrenching
process for the nation I resisted calls
to undertake an impeachment
investigations for many months on that
basis notwithstanding the existence of
presidential conduct I believed to be
deeply unethical and damaging to our
country the alarming offense in actions
detailed in this report however left us
with no choice but to proceed and then
he talks about the founding fathers yes
I'm sure that the founding fathers the
founding by the way the founding fathers
would looked at the activity of Trump
here and they were thought impeachable
hmm the reason being impeachment has
only been used against a president three
times in our nation's history okay once
it never never has it actually been used
to remove a president what is the exact
what what is the exact angle on the
impeachment so they say here's the
executive summary of the of the charges
they're only two charges abuse of power
and obstruction okay what exactly are
the charges one the president
conditioned a White House meeting and
military aides Ukraine on a public
announcement of investigations and
official to his re-election campaign
okay that is too vague to be an
impeachable crime you know what
presidents do all the time they do
things beneficial to their re-election
campaign when Barack Obama said I repeat
myself because I've said this often but
it's remains true when Barack Obama said
to Dmitry Medvedev
if you tell Vladimir Putin to back off I
will provide flexibility to the Russians
in my next term on a hot mic that was
him conditioning something to the
Russians on behalf of a reelection
campaign that's what that was that was
not illegal it was bad it was ugly it
was not impeachable in fact as it turns
out presidents frequently have an eye on
their reelect efforts when they do
foreign policy so the fact that it was
beneficial does not answer the question
the chief question in this entire
inquiry remember where this started it
started with the accusation that Donald
Trump specifically and maliciously
withheld aid to Ukraine military aids
Ukraine in a time of war in order to
force the Ukrainians to go after a 2020
political opponent Joe Biden wasn't
about 2016 wasn't about CrowdStrike
wasn't about Ukrainian corruption wasn't
about Ukrainian interference wasn't
about any of that stuff who's about Joe
Biden but now the Democrats have morphed
the charges and once you morph the
charges they're no longer impeachable
see the Democrats made a strategic error
here they should have pushed for some
sort of censure if they push for censure
they could have gotten Republicans on
the record saying Trump did nothing
wrong they could have said look at all
this bad stuff yeah it's not impeach
blow but it's bad stuff let's censure of
the president let's vote for censure and
then you get Republicans presumably
who'd feel torn right you get the Mitt
Romney's of the Senate going well maybe
I should vote for censure and get some
of the more moderate members of the
House going well you vote for centuries
not ousted no real impact there but the
Democrats went for broke it's a lot
easier for Republicans to say not
impeachable than not censurable a
democrats decide to go whole hog
they were playing chicken and it turns
out that you can only play chicken if
there's somebody else playing with you
okay but in order to play chicken you
actually have to have the goods they
didn't have the goods they put the brick
on the accelerator and now instead of
playing chicken with somebody they're
just flying off that cliff like Delma
and Louise and the polls show this
Americans are not supremely excited
about this impeachment effort so the
claim of Adam chef is that the president
conditioned a White House meeting and
military aides Ukraine on a public
announcement of investigations
beneficial to his reelection campaign
again it would have to be that his
intent which has not been established by
any testimony was purely about getting
Joe Biden for 2020 that's what would
have to be shown they did not achieve
that burden of proof they've not even
come close to achieving that burden of
proof and then Schiff
says that the president obstructed the
House of Representatives impeachment
inquiry
he said he instructed witnesses and
agencies to ignore subpoenas for
documents in testimony that's not
obstruction that is not legal
obstruction legal obstruction is when
you get a court order that orders you to
turn over the documents and then you say
no the way that a subpoena normally
works it even works this way with
interrogatories in depositions is that
you get a request for stuff and then you
are allowed to reply and say no and then
a court adjudicates whether you are
allowed to say no or not shift didn't
even go through this process not with
Giuliani now with Pompeo not with Mick
Mulvaney now with anybody now it pens
with no one there is no one who has
defied a legal subpoena from the house
no one it is not defying the subpoena to
say no and then file a court case which
is what john bolton did for example so
that's just a lie they don't have the
goods bottom line is they don't have the
goods and as it turns out every piece of
evidence that's coming out supports my
case as to what Trump was doing here not
the Democrats case not Trump's case
either right Trump says this was purely
about corruption
all I cared about was corruption there
was no quid pro quo I don't think that
the evidence supports that but it does
not support the actual impeachment case
of the Democrats either the story I've
been telling since pretty much the very
beginning when it became clear that
there was in fact some sort of quid pro
quo right Trump was withholding military
aid for a reason and then gave up be
withholding as soon as it became public
what that was really about was Trump
being obsessive about the 2016 election
buying into bad information provided him
by Rudy Giuliani bad decision making
sure foolish absolutely impeachable not
even close
really not impeachable that stuff you
take into consideration during an
election it's not stuff that you take
into consideration in an impeachable
hearing but the and by the way the
Democrats are basically saying this
stuff out loud now right Adam Chef was
asked specifically why don't you just
wait on some of the witnesses who might
know Trump's intent the Democrats so far
have brought forth one grand total of
one witness who had a conversation with
Trump one gordon someone that's it and
Gordon Sunland did not testify that
trumps intent was to get Joe Biden in
advance of the 20/20 election he did not
testify to that in fact not one Democrat
witness could actually substantiate
these cortical bribery allegations
Democrats are making not one so Schiff
was asked why don't just wait right why
don't you just wait for the results of
the subpoena while you wait for Giuliani
to testify in Bolton to testify and
mauvais need to testify in pens to
testify these are all people when
conversations with Trump why don't you
just wait and she was like we can't wait
for the facts when someone says you
can't wait for the facts that's because
they don't they know the facts ain't
gonna come in on their side here's Adam
Schiff just basically blowing a hole in
his own case if we do uncover additional
evidence and and we do learn more every
day we will feel free to file
supplemental reports to the Judiciary
Committee but there is I think rave risk
to the country with waiting until we
have every last fact when we already
know enough about the president's
misconduct to make a responsible
judgment okay again no you don't because
it was an intense crime bribery is an
intense crime intense is an element of
the crime
hey this is not a case where the
Democrats have the evidence and you can
see this in like the very first words of
shifts 300-page report and when he makes
the case that the president requested a
political favor
he again does not actually have the
evidence to back this up and he
certainly doesn't have the evidence for
obstruction right that that one just
does not exist that's not there at all
in fact there's a Washington Post piece
today about the origins of Ukraine
pressure campaign by Rosalyn held him in
and completely undercuts the Democrat
case remember the Democrat case to
reiterate again was about Donald Trump
trying to win the 2020 election by using
Ukraine's gears of justice to grind Joe
Biden like that was the that was the
claim but here's an article from the
Washington Post title how the Ukraine
pressure campaign began as an effort to
undercut the Moller investigation does
that have anything to do 2020 the MoMA
investigation was in fact an ongoing
thing in the United States it was and as
it turns out if Trump was being fed bad
information by Rudy Giuliani about
Ukrainian interference in the election
and then he acted on the basis of that
bad information again that maybe bad
judgment betting impeachable president's
act on the basis of bad information all
the time in fact Barack Obama did with
with Iran on a routine basis this piece
from The Washington Post says Special
Counsel Robert Muller had secured the
cooperation of trumps one-time fixer
Michael Cohen and appeared to be
prepping to incite a longtime adviser
Roger stone from former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort was in jail
it was in this uncertain moment that
trumps personal attorney Rudy Giuliani
said he had the idea to focus on Ukraine
that November he received a tip from
former colleagues that it was the
Ukrainians had conspired to help
Democrats in 2016 Giuliani said in
recent interviews Giuliani's efforts to
undermine the Special Counsel probe
eventually snowballed into the current
impeachment crisis gripping the Capitol
highlighting how the pressure Trump and
his allies put on Ukraine originated as
an effort to sow doubts about the Russia
investigation alternative reading the
entire effort began as an attempt to
gather more information about the 2016
election campaign if we expended tens of
millions of dollars to investigate
Russian interference in the 2016
campaign that Trump then Trump even on
the basis of bad information in using
American resources to pressure Ukraine
to cooperate on an investigation into
Ukrainian interference into 2016
it may be stupid it is not in fact
impeachable hey the Washington Post is
admitting as much it's admitting as much
so this whole thing is a sham it's gonna
move forward it's what I'm not paying
too much attention to we all know where
this is going
if Democrats are smart we'll get it over
with quick because once this hits the
Senate it's gonna get a lot uglier for
them Joe Biden hundred Biden will be
called in there will be serious
questions asked about Alexander chalupa
the DNC operative who's coordinating
with the Ukrainian embassy like there
will be witness is called the Democrats
don't want called it could get very ugly
very quickly okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today so peloton put
out this bike ad there is nothing wrong
with this bicycle ad it turns out on
Twitter people apparently were very
angry at this ad I'm gonna play the
admin explain why people were angry and
then I'm gonna explain why there's
nothing wrong with the ad because you
have to honestly you have to have been
hit on the head as a child repeatedly in
order to spot the problem with this ad
[Music]
this holiday give the gift of peloton
okay so do you see anything wrong with
that ad if you if you can't spot what's
wrong with that ads because you're a
member of the patriarchy you bastard
okay here's what's wrong with the ad
according to the left seriously what's
wrong with the ad is that the ad is
sexist don't you see the husband never
should have given his wife a peloton
because he was saying she was she was
that's what he was doing he wanted to be
sexier and so he gave her a peloton bite
right me that's really this is what
people are saying I'm not I'm not
kidding it there's an article in The
Washington Post called quote this
peloton ad is a dystopian fitness inspo
hellscape hellscape
hey the entire ad is just a woman
climbing on a bike and then taking this
video so she can pay it say thanks to
her husband after year because if alt
owns an expensive gift and talking about
how it's changed for life you know
exercise can actually make your life
better I know that breaking news
exercise can make you feel better even
if you're already in good shape and it
releases endorphins it makes your life
healthier all of these things but
apparently the only reason he want to
give his very skinny very attractive and
fit wife already a peloton is cuz she
was fat if she was f
fatso because he's a sexist and he wants
to have sex with a beautiful wife as
opposed to having sex with a slightly
less beautiful wife she probably lost
like six ounces over the course of that
ad and those six ounces that's what he
was after he wanted those six ounces
gone this is I'm not kidding this is
what people are saying that it's a the
this ad went nuts people weren't crazy
Brittany sham is writing for the
Washington Post the woman wears an eerie
expression as she climbs on to her new
palette on for the first time she's sort
of smiling sort of grimacing she looks
like she might burst into tears I'm a
little bit nervous but excited she says
not at all convincingly at the start of
the pricey stationary bicycle company's
new commercial it was a look that
spawned a thousand Twitter jokes to sum
the young mother who spends the majority
of her 30-second ad toiling away on the
bike after her husband gives it to her
for Christmas
looked like a hostage okay first of all
I have a wife who does not particularly
love exercising and every time she
starts to exercise she gives me that
same look and then she's happy afterward
so I totally sympathize with his ad
seriously it's it's hard to get started
it's it's hard to get started exercising
it is but it's not because the woman is
being pressured into riding a peloton
bike she's not being tortured by her
husband this is ridiculous
hey comedian eva victor exclaimed in a
widely shared parody video my husband
got me a peloton for christmas nothing
weird about that thank you
you get me okay again I have considered
getting my wife a peloton you know why
because she said that maybe she'd be
interested in a peloton because it
doesn't just I mean like I don't mean to
do an ad for peloton here but it's kind
of cool oh you got the stationary bike
and then you got the actual like live
sessions going on you get to be part
basically part of a fitness class live
every day that's pretty neat thing I've
considered getting a peloton and my wife
has talked to me about wanting one so is
this so terrible the company's stock
tumbled Tuesday by 9 percent on backlash
from this dumb stupid controversy the ad
made its debut last month on YouTube one
of the comments are turned off the ad
carried an innocuous title the gift that
gives back but too many watching the
star of the commercial didn't seem to
want it at all after the peloton is
foisted upon her because I do remember
the part of the ad where the husband
comes in and he actually changed her to
the bike and he says you're going to
bike woman you're going to bike until
that ass looks better you get a bike
until that ass comes right off
you remember that part of the ad I don't
because it's not in the ad because it's
crazy but apparently according to the
media and according to idiots on Twitter
that is an integral part of the ad
apparently at the at the end in a twist
something found to be a little too black
mirror she plays the montage of grueling
workouts for her husband the next
Christmas turning to him to watch his
reaction the peloton looms in the
background it was spousal abuse viewers
cried it was sexism a descent into
wellness hell society's Nightmare Before
Christmas vice said she would rather be
anywhere in the world than here in her
glacial home with the husband she loads
putting on this sick pantomime of
wellness and marital bliss she'd even
rather be back on the dreaded peloton
okay the whole thing is so stupid it's
so stupid there is nothing wrong with
you and there's just something wrong
with you
there's just nothing wrong with you if
you watch that and when you got out of
that is what a horrible husband who got
his wife a twenty eight two thousand
dollar bicycle so that she can exercise
when she sees fit and then she thanked
him for it what a horrible life she
leads if that's what you got out of that
it's cuz you're an idiot an idiot and
you're woke social justice warrior
garbage is nonsense and by the way if my
wife suggested that you want to be
healthier and so I got her a peloton
bike there's nothing wrong with that and
by the way if my wife were dramatically
overweight which she is not and I said
to her you know honey it would be more
healthy if you lost some weight that's
not me being a bad husband if she said
the same thing to me that's not her
being a bad wife being in a marriage
means communication about issues yes
including your health and wellness
there's nothing wrong with any of this
but the fact that it is now considered
sexist to get your wife a pretty nice
bike for Christmas
how dare he he's the real villain of the
piece he's like this Hitlerian figure
looming because just like Hitler he gave
somebody like you know like bicycles
Hitler let me tell you something about
sexism let me tell you something about
sexism sexism looms in giving women
bicycles I know this is Harvey
Weinstein's chief tactic when he was out
there victimizing women the first thing
he did he sent him a peloton he sent
them a peloton and then he tried to rape
them that was the prelude right there to
rape culture that was hashtag me to what
we watched right there you're all mutts
you're all crazy there's nothing wrong
with the ad if you think there is it's
cuz you dumb ok we've run out of time so
that was sort of a thing I like and a
thing I hate so we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise we
will see you here tomorrow so be there
or be square I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is my
Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]